bueno voy a contarles la historia
personal de cómo fue que yo llegué a ser
una creyente una convencida del valor de
los diálogos y del valor de crear
soluciones en consenso
en el año 98 el espacio público del
centro histórico de quito tenía una
permanente ocupación por parte del
comercio de la calle
en este momento había un estudio de la
empresa del centro histórico que daba
cuenta de 8 mil 200 comerciantes que
ocupaban más o menos un 20% del espacio
público en forma permanente el alcalde
de ese momento hace una decisión
política de intervención en la zona y de
tratar de encontrar una solución es que
fuera de trabajar el comercio no en la
calle del centro histórico esta decisión
estuvo antecedida de muchos otros
trabajos en relación a tratar de hacer
una contención del comercio que seguía
creciendo de que en algunas fechas de
navidad año nuevo no se ocupara de la
forma desbordante que se ocupaba esta
decisión política
está acompañada de la creación de un
equipo para trabajar en las posibles
soluciones se crean unas posibles
soluciones físicas para contar a los
comerciantes cuál sería una mejor opción
para ellos soluciones que fueron
pensadas en el escritorio de los
técnicos y sin salir a conversar en una
forma intensa con los comerciantes y a
partir de haberles contado estas
soluciones que técnicamente funcionaban
bastante bien hubo una
una no aceptación generalizada de estas
propuestas y hubo un momento de parar el
trabajo y de que este equipo pudiera
capacitarse para manejar esa
conversación de forma productiva para
hacer un manejo de la conversación con
unas herramientas que permitieran
manejarlo es decir para poder tener un
conocimiento de cómo manejar
pacíficamente un conflicto que venía de
muchos años y es así que el equipo
durante bastante semanas estuvo
trabajando en esa en esa capacitación y
volvió a salir de otra manera al
escenario del trabajo con los
comerciantes volvió a abrir el diálogo
con los comerciantes en este momento yo
era la administradora de la zona centro
del distrito metropolitano y por eso
forme parte de este equipo que trabajó
en esta negociación como tantos otros
pudieran estar contando la historia en
estos momentos
el cambio fue radical completamente a
las muchísimas reuniones que se tuvieron
empezaron a dar información que podía
ser útil para poder entregar unas
soluciones de consenso
los actores se convirtieron realmente en
actores la confrontación se fue
transformando en confianza mutua para
poder llegar a abordar un problema de
esas dimensiones y al cabo de 300
reuniones que se llevaron a efecto en
durante dos años en 80 de las cuales
participó el alcalde de ese momento el
70% de las organizaciones que estaban
agrupadas en 82 organizaciones los
comerciantes estas organizaciones en un
70% firmaron acuerdos con la
municipalidad al cabo de ese tiempo
vinieron las elecciones y ganó otra
persona a la alcaldía de su momento pero
el nivel de avance de las negociaciones
era tan grande que el proyecto atravesó
ese cambio político porque no ganó la
misma línea política y siguió el
proyecto con una madurez institucional
que le dio el nuevo alcalde y en mucho
por él la calidad de ese proceso
anterior por la calidad que tuvo este
proceso de escucha
finalmente en el año 2004 recién cuando
ya había transcurrido todo el primer
periodo de esta nueva alcaldía se
produce la reubicación porque había
obviamente que terminar de construir
muchas cosas que ya hizo la siguiente
alcaldía
qué
cuál fue la lección inmensa aprendida
por todo ese equipo muchos de los cuales
han seguido en estos trabajos fue el
poder que tiene la herramienta de
escuchar porque la escucha y el diálogo
no es la solución como tal es la
herramienta tal como si tuviéramos unas
herramientas para construir algo físico
si estamos trabajando con las
herramientas adecuadas se va a facilitar
la construcción física de algo y yo que
soy arquitecta sentía algo muy parecido
cuando iba ocurriendo esta esta escucha
productiva si esta escucha que iba
cerrando poco a poco esa inmensa brecha
de confrontación para abrir también poco
a poco la posibilidad de la confianza
la posibilidad de que los intereses
reales de los actores de ese momento
salieran a la luz y no siguieran
posicionados en hechos que no iban a
poder generar una solución
las soluciones de consenso no nos
satisfacen todos todos los intereses ni
solucionan todos los problemas ningún
método lo hace pero sí es verdad que a
través de personalmente y
profesionalmente a través del
descubrimiento en la práctica de el
poder de esa herramienta es que se ha
podido trabajar en otras áreas también
importantes pero este caso los sacó a la
luz porque es un caso que se sostuvo en
el tiempo gracias a la calidad que tuvo
ese proceso en ese momento del de la
ciudad con esas herramientas que
teníamos y creo que él
he hecho de haber
atravesado el riesgo político de abrir
un proceso de diálogo porque un proceso
de diálogo conlleva un riesgo conlleva
más riesgos no hacer el proceso de
diálogo pero eso es un poco invisible
todavía pero el abrir un proceso de
diálogo obviamente tienes que enfrentar
un riesgo político que en ese momento
fue enfrentado y se atravesó por
enfrentarlo entonces la
y soluciones a las que se llegaron
habiendo venido de un consenso tuvieron
más posibilidad de sostenerse en el
tiempo eso es otra de las virtudes de
hacer un proceso dialogado sidenor de la
no imposición sino de tener un proceso
de diálogo detrás de las soluciones que
se den a un problema en este caso a la
ocupación del comercio de las calles de
quito por parte del comercio que estaba
en ese momento por ejemplo una un
término utilizado desde ese momento que
fue comercio comerciantes y comercio
minorista fue nacido del diálogo antes
había otras denominaciones que se les
vendían a los comerciantes de ese
momento y que importante que fue ese
nombre porque también surgió del detalle
de la escucha
era el tamaño de los puestos al
principio era una demanda muy grande
tener puestos lo más grandes posibles
pero cuando conversábamos de por qué la
municipalidad tenía que poner unos
subsidios y arreglar todos los temas era
porque era un comercio minorista que
requería un apoyo para continuar
entonces cuando en un patio se construyó
un simulacro de puesto pequeño de 6
metros cuadrados y se colgó toda la ropa
y los zapatos que cabían ahí se vio que
era suficientemente grande como para
exhibir lo que ellos podían invertir
como capital como comerciantes minorista
que es a donde atacaba el problema pero
todo eso fue un producto de una escucha
organizada por llamarle de alguna forma
de haber abierto ese proceso
qué utilidad puede tener en estos
momentos que atravesamos algunos barrios
ciudades países pues toda la utilidad
parece que lo que más falta nos está
haciendo es conversar dialogar
entre ciudadanos entre barrios y entre
nuestros países también
y estas situaciones que actualmente
vivimos muy probablemente detrás de
algunas de ellas subyace un silencio un
no diálogo
muchas muchas muchos temas sin hablar
cuando yo veo que hay una gran
manifestación tengo muchísima curiosidad
de saber la razón por la que cada uno
manifiesta porque seguramente en esa
razón a través de un proceso de escucha
vienen algunas soluciones que de otra
manera tal vez no serían posibles
y esto yo creo que se aplica desde una
escala muy pequeña en el centro
histórico o se trabajó posteriormente
por un tema que parecía pequeño que era
el tema de los chicles en el suelo del
centro histórico todo todas las personas
comían chicle y lo votaban en el suelo y
es teníamos una alfombra de chicles y
para poderlo trabajar el tema se
conversó con las empresas dos que
fabricaban chicles para explicar que
teníamos un problema que no queríamos
que dejen de vender chicles pero
necesitábamos limpiar y fue con las
primeras que se trabajó este tema y
luego con los colegios se trazó en
metros cuadrados las plazas del centro
histórico y cada niño con todo un metro
cuadrado cuántos chicles habían dentro
del metro cuadrado y después se
multiplicó por el número de metros
cuadrados y en plazas como santodomingo
habían más de 70 mil chicles
que poco a poco las personas iban a
dejar de tirarlos en el suelo desde
luego todos estos son procesos que
necesitan una continuidad que es el otro
elemento del factor muy importante los
cambios políticos crean una
incertidumbre tan fuerte en todos estos
procesos que es algo que tenemos que
inventar una una solución para esa
temática finalmente mi ilusión en estos
momentos que
los temas de los que tal vez no estamos
dialogando lo suficiente en nuestro país
en nuestras ciudades puedan ser motivo
de conversación la pobreza
la crisis humanitaria de la migración
el racismo la calidad del aire
tenemos que sentarnos a hablar de todo
esto por incómodo que sea las
conversaciones no son siempre cómodas el
diálogo no es siempre cómodo
tenemos que incomodar nos
para estar mejor
finalmente para convivir que es de lo
que se trata
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]